-I want to talk, though,
about your beginnings.
You first started acting,
you were in L.A...
-Yes.
-...going to school
to be an actor.
-Born and raised, yeah.
-And Central Casting,
and they put this up
on Instagram recently,
that three of the stars
in the show, there you are
in today's day.
-Mm-hmm.
There you are, that that's me.
-That's you.
-That's me, yeah.
I look very different
on the show.
-I have to say, like,
you do things that
I would not have predicted.
-Chameleon!
-So, these are
your original head shots,
the three of you.
So, what was Central Casting?
-Central Casting is
background-actors' casting,
so when you watch anything
and it looks like people
are just living their life
and there's strangers
walking around them,
those are all paid actors
who are just "extras"...
-Yeah.
-...in the background,
and for one summer
during college,
I did that as,
like, my summer job.
I had never been
on a set before.
I was going to theater school,
and the RA from my building
graduated and was working
for Central Casting.
So he was like,
"Oh, come do this.
And I'll get you all
the 'good' extra jobs."
-So, what's a "good" extra job?
-Well, I had a couple.
I was definitely, like,
on that show "American Dreams"
and would be, like,
one of five girls
smoking a cigarette
in the bathroom
while, like,
a scene was happening.
Um, most notably,
I got to play a dead body...
-See, that's great.
-...on "NYPD Blue"...
-That's really great.
-...in the
Mark-Paul Gosselaar years.
I'm not sure how long --
was he always on that show?
-No, he was on,
like, at the tail-end.
I feel like
the last couple years, yeah.
-When he was on,
which was major for me
because I am a huge
"Saved by the Bell" fan
and grew up watching
that so much.
So I was just like,
"Oh, my God.
What am I gonna do
when I see him?"
-Every time you watched
"Saved by the Bell"
you were like, "Oh, my God.
I would be so psyched to be dead
in front of Zack."
[ Audience laughs ]
-My dream is to be,
like, lying, holding my breath
in front of Zack Morris,
and have him pull a receipt
out of my pocket,
which was the action that he did
on the show.
It was, like, a major clue
of the episode.
-So, you have to be
a dead person...
-I'm dead, like, in a closet.
-Gotcha.
-And he finds me
with another cop,
and they, like,
squat and have a serious scene,
and then they find a receipt
and, like, pull it
out of my pocket.
I was so excited about it.
When it aired, it was just legs.
It was just my legs.
[ Audience laughs ]
And that receipt, you know,
and it's the worst
'cause being a dead body
is actually quite challenging.
I've played a few.
-Oh, I'm sure it was harder
than what
Mark Gosselaar was doing.
-Yeah.
He's like, "Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-I'm having to, like,
really be --
"inhabit the corpse" mind-set...
-Yeah.
-...and feel dead,
and hold your breath,
like, 'cause they're like,
"Background girl, stop.
We can see you breathing.
You're not holding your breath."
-Yeah!
And then, they've got to rifle
through your pockets!
That can't be easy.
-Yeah, and they're,
like, touching your body
and you're, like,
pretending not to be excited.
[ Audience laughs ]
-It's like dead bodies just,
like, don't react to, like,
their high school crushes.
-The director was, like,
a real Nazi about not reacting.
-I was like, "She's dead,
but she's not that dead."
[ Audience laughs ]
-And then, so that is obviously
incredibly important work.
-Yes, it was good.
-But you also did some --
You were a clown.
You did some clowning.
-Yes, prior to this.
In preparation for.
-So, clown was before this.
It goes clown, dead body,
where you are now.
-Yeah, and then now!
That's just like every actor's
normal trajectory.
So, when I was in high school,
maybe right after high school --
'cause again, these are,
like, my summer jobs.
-Right.
-Um, I worked as a clown.
Some of my friends
from Drama class
became clowns.
I'm going to do the rest
of the story like this.
-[ Laughs ]
-I have a weird tic these days.
Um, so, it was
a bounce house company.
who was just getting
into the clown game.
-Right.
-So they...
-Well, you're already
on the lost, so to speak.
If people are going to pay
for a bounce house,
they might throw in money.
-Maybe they also want that.
So, it was out of
this huge warehouse in Compton,
"Straight Outta Compton."
[ Audience laughs ]
-Well, that does establish
you don't -- I will say I saw
"Straight Outta Compton"
the film, and I don't remember
a single clown.
-It got cut for time.
I think it got cut for time.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
I saw a dead clown's legs,
but was that you?
[ Audience laughs ]
-And it was comical.
I mean, I grew up
in Los Angeles
in South Pasadena,
which is not quite
the same thing,
and before every party,
you had to go to
the warehouse in Compton,
pick up your clown outfit,
like, do your clown makeup,
and then go to
the nearest gas station
because they paid us
for gas mileage,
so they were, like,
measuring from the place.
And so, just picture me.
I'm 17 years old.
I have, like, a yellow fro.
My clown name is Sunny.
And I'm just, like,
pumping gas in Compton
like it ain't no thing.
And definitely, it was not.
Nobody cared.
I was like, "Oh, my God.
What's gonna happen?"
And people were like,
"What's up, clown?"
[ Audience laughs ]
I was like, "Cool."